what's going on everybody welcome to yet
another python 3 basics tutorial video
in this video we're going to be talking
about dictionaries so dictionaries are
kind of they're really python specific
but they're a lot like associative
arrays in other languages
um and the idea of them is they're an
unordered unordered
unordered assortment of data and the
data is always keys and values and again
it's unordered so you might enter it in
an order and then you might expect an
order out of it or maybe you want to
order your dictionary you you can kind
of hacky order a dictionary but not
really
there is no order inherently up to a
dictionary so
anyway again the idea of a dictionary is
to have keys and values a key will be a
single element
values can be anything it can be
lists it could be lists within lists or
multi-dimensional lists your values can
be functions which can get exciting fast
uh can be anything so anyway
with that you can even reference another
dictionary in a dictionary so
yeah
let's go ahead and show some examples so
we're going to say x dix equals
and to notify python that you're going
to create a dictionary use curly braces
and then within the curly braces let's
say we have a collection of people
and their ages so we're going to say we
got jack he's 15 years old we have
ourselves a bob who is 22
we have ourselves an alice who is
she's 12
and then we finally have a kevin
and kevin is 17 years old okay so it is
example dick now just for quick
uh kicks
print example dicks just to see how
python reads it as you can see it's
almost an exact printout of exactly what
we just typed easy enough
now what if we want to reference
something in this dictionary we want to
ask this dictionary hey how old is jack
example dick
well you go print
eggs xdix
and
g whoops jack so this should be kind of
familiar to you guys as far as
lists are concerned we're kind of
referencing a bit of data and so
jack is the key
and then the value is this number right
here so hopefully it's going to tell us
15.
sure enough it does now
uh the next thing that we're going to do
is we found out how old jack is that's
cool we can reference this how do we
let's say we want to add something to
this list
so for example let's say we want to add
tim so to do that we'll say exac exdict
tim so this is basically exactly how we
reference jack right we said x dick jack
just print out that that value now we're
saying ex dick tim which doesn't exist
already but we're about to make it exist
he's 14.
okay so now we can print
[ __ ] save and run it itchy ears sorry
guys
and then we have tim okay so see how it
kind of just added to him like almost
like a randomly into this um so yeah
keep that in mind it's there's no order
really to it but anyway it added tim
now let's say uh tim just turned 15
years old big one five so now we're
going to say example dict
10
equals 15. so as you can see we already
defined tim here and now we're like
redefining tim
um
and so you'll see this is why
dictionaries have to have
unique keys otherwise everything would
fall apart the sky would literally fall
whoops we need to print tim again uh so
example a little dick timmy was 15. look
how it it's uh this this time right like
this time i put tim's second this time
it puts tim all the way at the end wow
crazy stuff anyway tim's 15 don't print
example dicks
and we can see at first tim was 14 now
tim is 15. fancy
that
sadly however tim has died we need to
remove him from this list he's no use
being in this list anymore he's dead so
now how do we get rid of this tim guy
well
let's make some space here
now to get rid of something we can just
do
dell deo
example dict
tim
this is going to remove the key and
value or values to 10.
whoops we got to let's print it out
after
deleting
eggs dicks
so he was here
great 14 turn 15 good for him then he
died
bummer now he's dead done
so
um now just as a quick aside so this is
our list let me get rid of all this now
and let's say instead or not instead but
now
not only are we tracking age but we're
going to track hair color
so jack he's 15.
and his hair color is blonde
bob is 22
and bob's hair color is
uh
what color is bob's hair brown i heard
brown from the crowd
now alice
alice is 12 years old
but alice's hair is black
and we're not a space but here's kevin
kevin's a ginger so he's got red head
sorry if i offended anybody
um there we go good now we can print
let's do print
example date uh jack
oh okay
my spidey stance was tingling that i did
something and i sure did
python 27 coming out of me anyway
15 and blonde okay correct and we can
even go like this we can say well we
want to reference just his hair color
boom blonde nice okay so this list could
go forever if you wanted you could also
create other dictionaries and you could
say jack is equal to another dictionary
you can create functions and say jack is
equal to a function
um you do all kinds of stuff we'll
probably expand on that a little bit
more once i get through all of the kind
of basic things i want to get through
with python three
then we'll get into some more in-depth
kind of hacky things some more
intermediate things that kind of stuff
so anyways if you guys have any
questions or comments feel free to leave
those below also i'm still kind of
making this series probably some of you
first viewers to the series
um
i'll still be generating this python 3
series if you have any
requests or anything you definitely want
to see i highly suggest you request them
that way they show up for you guys
but
anyway someone's at the door so i'm
gonna conclude this video here if you
guys have any questions or comments
leave them below as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support
subscriptions and until next time